good afternoon good evening I always
enjoy banging on the gavel
welcome to planning committee Easter
night
this is an unusual meeting so there may
be the occasions one I might have to
bang my gavel again so seek advice so
what the Romano gentleman so don't be
surprised if I do occasionally bang the
gavel so it's nothing personal
I just like to introduce my fellow
members from committee services Ross
chambers legal service
right that's most guys thank you
gentlemen for turning up and adding your
knowledge and experience it was sure I'm
sure you're keen to impart light si
thank you very much the procedure for
the meeting was agreed at the meeting on
the 2nd of May 2019 and we will start
with mr. Grafton who will be presenting
the report sir Thank You chairman and
perhaps I ought to introduce myself
because I wear a number of different
hats in this council but the hat I'm
wearing tonight is of head of governance
and democracy and I ought to as well
introduce the other parties in the room
who will accord you to the procedure be
addressing you later today
the first is councilor of Donnell and
also I think we have in the room Robert
Walton who represents who represents the
planning applicant I'd like to use my
time to deal with two separate aspects
one is just to rehearse a little bit
what happened at the previous planning
committee in terms of process so that's
part one and secondly I'd like some time
to address you in relation to the
substantive issue that of the question
of the revocation of this planning
application so if I can deal with the
first point first you'll remember as the
chairman said that you last met on this
on the 2nd of May and at that meeting
you made certain resolutions as to have
you were going to conduct today's
meeting the request is from councillor
O'Donnell for the revocation of a
planning permission and listed building
consent for white house farm and my
report to the last meeting which is
before you in the agenda today
included three recommendations but in
fact to date we have only dealt with
recommendation one that's the procedure
just to rehearse what your decisions
were you agreed with the with the
suggested process that I'd set out in
paragraph one point eighteen of my
report those are the ten procedural
issues you'd agreed at that time that
you were going to increase the speaking
time noting that I'd suggested five
minutes to ten minutes and you'd also
agreed that any discussion of papers on
blue paper would have to take part in
private session and you would exclude
the public and the press from that just
to note at this point that one of the
documents that's on blue as in the last
meeting should not be on blue it should
be on white and that is the advice from
the barrister which is at pages 57 to 63
of your pact and I don't know whether
democratic services have yet done it but
if you would like to distribute copies
of that okay okay so as long as that's
understood that the advice itself is in
the public domain and you can discuss
that quite freely but the remainder of
the papers on blue you would had agreed
would remain on blue as I say that you
would ask the public and the press to
leave if you were going to discuss that
lastly you've resolved that if you had
any points of clarification about any of
the issues you would either ask myself
or your legal adviser Ross chambers so
assuming that the processes you agreed
on the last occasion is now where we are
I'm ready to address you
in relation to the request itself
I do understand from speaking to
counselor O'Donnell a few minutes ago
that there might be some issues in
relation to things that she wants to
present to the committee specifically my
understanding is that she wants to show
you extracts from the webcast of the
planning committee meeting on the 2nd of
August last year when those planning
permission and listed building consent
was agreed yeah if if that indeed is her
request and I think she probably needs
to address you on that I can say quite
straight away that I would have certain
reservations about that and I would want
to address you on that point I think
maybe I should stop at this point as I
say there is a there is a part two to my
to my talk to you which is about getting
to the substantive issue but if I can
pause there it might be that you want to
hear further about that particular
matter
I might get talking this but can you
explain to me why you think there will
be a problem in showing video clips I'd
like to hear that now that's why I asked
the question I've been able to ask that
question just repeat up why why would
there be a problem in showing clips from
a video that is already publicly
available there are two reasons firstly
that the the the underlying basis for
the request for revocation is around
advice that the planning manager is a
delay is alleged to have given to the
committee this webcast plays for quite a
considerable time certainly over an hour
and that particular advice only takes up
a sure
time and secondly it is encapsulated in
the legal advice that I've just referred
to that the barrister went into so she
has encapsulated all the concerns that
were raised as part of the original
letter that was requesting revocation
and she has given her view so my point
would be what on earth do you need to
see the webcast for bearing in mind that
you've got all the evidence and the
opinion about that matter in the second
point would be if you are minded to
accept the webcast then why would you be
wanting to see selected edited parts of
the webcast bearing in mind that you
won't see the context in which those
comments were made my major point would
be either you see everything in which
case you might want to adjourn or you
see nothing and you rely on the papers
that you have before you this is gonna
be a comment rather than a question
clearly any advice that we're gonna be
reading is based on one person's opinion
I can only assume they've seen the video
if we're gonna make any form of decision
or any form or have any form of
worthwhile debate tonight I believe we
should have all evidence and that
includes this video so I feel we should
have full sight of that entire video if
that's what's required in order for us
to be on make an appropriate decision I
don't think we can move forward without
seeing that video so I think we we have
to see the whole thing okay I'll listen
to counsel brains comments and I've got
a view as well but I think we should see
that if we're going to see the video we
see it in totality not in bit clips
that's the bonds somebody picked a break
out of this and the bitter edge of that
you don't get a true reflection of
actually what happened so as far as I'm
concerned so I tend to grease or they're
all or nothing
I'll just need to consult with my legal
advisor Tamar right just about the
process for watching them that in the
you jet where they will need to adjourn
because I believe this is it to oversee
did you say around half so I just just
need to speak to second yeah I think if
you want to watch the whole meeting is
about an hour and a half but as mr.
Grafton says the the the parts of the
meeting which under scrutiny are set out
in the papers so in my view it's
completely down to you but in my view
there isn't the need to watch the
meeting it's all it's all described in
the papers
very Sarah I can't make you speak at the
moment you've had to speak later on but
in the process I can't let you speak at
the moment I'm afraid
yeah
cancer Richards so you obviously know
that I was pointed as a sub late last
night I've only had the benefit of this
advice in the last 90 minutes if we're
going to rely on this solely and not the
video I'm going to need 10 minutes to
read and absorb this and confirm to
myself that actually everything is
covered in here before we before we
proceed I'm happy to adhere well I think
we need to decide whether we want it or
not
what's the whole clip or whether they're
happy to proceed so I'm I'm seeking
advice from committee whether we want to
do that first and then if we do decide
then we can potentially adjourn council
riches for just go back to kiss the
cargo first and then come back to you I
agree I think that the reason of
information within the body of the
document forced to make a decision on
that
I don't need necessarily to hear the
clips so I'm happy to if you want to I'm
uncomfortable making that decision
because I haven't had the opportunity to
read and absorb this advice fully and so
I want to read that before I decide
whether or not the clip is worth
watching
so I'm looking really I'm looking for
some guidance from committee informal
proposal I propose we adjourn so I can
read this all those in favor I think we
adjourn until 22 so it's just over 10
minutes
thank you very much well what worries in
cancer Richards would you watch spanner
okay well I think we need to make a
decision with the excerpts on the
webcast so we haven't got it you know as
chair I believe that I couldn't make
decision but I'm minded to ask committee
to make this decision
so it's everybody has their say on this
matter so again Richard would you not
yeah thought should we be inviting
cancer Donna to explain to us why she
feels that they are required if we are
to if we were to is that something that
we as a committee have the right to do
given we haven't actually been asked to
look at them yet yeah I'm not minded to
I'm concerned that we agreed the process
on the second of by of how we would run
this meeting and we deferred and then
came back it was only till today that we
heard we're burger potentially be asked
to look at these items off the webcast
which is not in keeping with our usual
procedures so I find that very strange
ashamed wasn't mentioned before so
that's that's why I'm so caca I post me
I'm happy to continue without the clips
I'm sure that counselor Donna will be
speaking for a period and she can
explain during that time as well she's
got a period of time to speak how much
on we've got to decide but I mean
okay thank you I think we need to divide
that I'll thank you very much our
opinions thank you very much mr. Afton
Thank You chairman so so now moving on
to the actual substantive issue before
you which of course is the request for
revocation if you turn to to my report
at page five starts at paragraph one
point two to leave at one point one
point two one the legal test on whether
to or not to revoke so there we have
some general legal principles around
decisions on revoking planning
applications and the two points to take
from that are that you must take into
account for the development plan and you
must take into account the public
interest in making a revocation order
and I'll come back to that point about
public interest in a moment and then at
122 there are some matters which you may
take into account as material
considerations when you're considering
making an order and in this particular
case the only material consideration has
been raised by the requester as you'll
seen a letter that's in the PAC is the
the alleged procedural flaw in the
process by which the planning
application was granted last August so
as you know
from the first report that is in effect
that the planning manager had misled the
planning committee when it was
considering those issues back in August
last year and particularly when advising
on what the planning inspectors decision
was in the basis for that decision on
the appeal for the two previous
applications for the site those
allegations were then considered by the
specialist planning barrister whose name
is Annabel gray and Paul and you have
seen the advice that she has produced so
what I want to do is just basically pick
up a couple of points that she's raised
in that advice to deal with those
grounds so if you can turn to page we
start at page 58 of your PAC paragraph
13 importantly she says that she has
watched the relevant part of the
transcript at paragraph 17 on the next
page she correctly identifies the issue
that she's asked to advise on ie point 1
whether the planning manager actually
misled the committee if you turn over
the page and look at paragraph 20 she
then defines the legal test as to
whether the planning officer may have
misled the committee and she actually
then distinguishes between what she
calls minor or inconsequential errors
which she says may be excused with at
paragraph 21 where the line is drawn
between an officer's advice that is
significantly or seriously misleading
she says misleading in a material way an
advice that he's misleading but not
significantly sir
and then she deals with some case law
that helps to define the boundaries
between what is significantly misleading
and what is not at paragraph 23 on the
top of page 61 and I must just quote
this it begins it's the second sentence
at the pop top of page 61 she says that
what the inspector had said was that
harm can be outweighed by the benefits
of reusing at historic building however
he said that it was not on the scheme
before him and he did not say that it
necessarily would be in any future
scheme the officer appeared to be saying
to the members that the inspector had
found that the harm was in fact
outweighed by the reuse of the building
but there were separate design flaws
which meant that permission was not
granted so she's clearly outlined there
the difference between what the officer
appeared to be saying to the committee
and what the inspector actually said and
then crucially at paragraph 25 and I'm
going to quote again she says having
said that I do not consider that members
were significantly misled they had
before them an accurate officers report
which did not misrepresent the
inspectors conclusions and and I will
come back to that point about the the
report further the distinction the
officer ought to have made is a
relatively minor one because the main
point is that members needed to balance
the harm against the public benefits of
reusing the building which they did
reaching the conclusion that they could
not find any planning grants for finding
that the harm was outweighed the point
being that she had clearly identified
the issue that was he was asked to
advise on she had given details of the
legal test around that she had
distinguished between significant errors
and not significant errors she had set
out exactly what the difference was
between what the officer had told the
committee and what the inspector had
said
rapport and she had a paragraph 25 come
to the conclusion that in her view as a
specialist power planning barrister that
that the planning manager had not
significantly led the committee and if
you go through to paragraph 34 which is
on page 63 she says once again topic
page 63 in conclusion in my view the
officer did not seriously mislead
mislead the members so just going or I
don't need to turn to the planning
officers report which is what I want to
draw your attention to is if you go to
page 25 of your pack it's actually
labels as well as page 67 but that's
page 67 there's something different
right at the top of that page again I'm
going to quote to make no apologies for
this this is the report of the planning
officer aeryn whether stone when
reporting to the committee on the 2nd of
August last year having considered the
details submitted and the inspectors
previous decision which is a material
consideration to which I thought
considerable weight I am satisfied that
the conversion of the building into
three dwellings is the most viable
option for the securing the heritage
asset in the long term in line with the
requires that policy AS tends to secure
its ongoing maintenance having regard to
the above I therefore consider that the
principle of the development is
supported by policy a s10 and policy cs8
where there are public benefits to
outweigh the less than substantial harm
identified other material considerations
are therefore assessed below
she then repeats to an extent that view
if you go to page 31 top of page 31 she
says the proposal would result in three
new dwellings for which future occupiers
would be highly reliant on the use of
the private car to
to access day-to-day services and
facilities however I consider that the
unsustainable development and lessen
substantial harm identified would be
outweighed by the public benefit of
securing the long-term maintenance of
the heritage asset and adjoining
buildings the point I'm making is that
the barrister correctly states that the
members of the committee who were
determining that application had an
accurate description of the position
before them from the planning officer
and that has led at least partially to
her view that the planning manager had
not significantly misled the committee
so now just returning to paragraph 1.2 2
of my report which is listing all those
different factors that can be taken into
account as material considerations I'd
like just to go through each of them so
with point a the compensation you will
see from your pack that there has been a
letter from the developer solicitor and
if you want the reference it is at page
50 of your pack and all I want to point
out there is towards the bottom of that
page you have some headings one two
three and at that point in time the
solicitor acting for the planning
applicant was telling us that to date
they had spent twenty four twenty four
and a half thousand pounds and at number
two in terms of loss or damage rightly
attributable to the revocation they were
talking in terms of hundreds of
thousands of pounds no doubt you can
hear more from the other parties to this
point point B the prejudice to the
landowner and the developer again I'm
going to leave that to the planning
applicants barrister my only thought on
this was if you are minded to make a
revocation order and indeed that is your
final decision then would the developer
be consenting to the revocation order
because without that positive consent
the matter falls to be considered by the
Secretary of State or would indeed this
go to Secretary of State for
determination in a case that the local
planning authority wanted to make the
order with regard to point C this is a
more interesting question we're talking
about the public interest here and the
question arises what do we mean by the
public
trust who are the public is it the six
residents who are directly living next
to the application site is it the local
community of Italy code or is it indeed
as I would argue the the reasonable
taxpayer
across this district and if they were
asked whether this kind of money should
be spent to buy back a planning
permission in a situation where external
legal advice confirms that the grounds
for the revocation are not made out what
would I ask
they say if then if their money was in
effect only going to directly benefit
six tax payers and I leave that thought
in your mind point D about the
seriousness of the legal errors is a
point I've already discussed and will
leave with you to consider that point e
the length of time that has elapsed
since the permission is granted and the
steps taken in reliance on the
permission is largely a question for the
barrister for the developer to talk
about and but as far as point F is
concerned as my report pointed out at
the last committee meeting there was
never any legal challenge whether by
judicial review or otherwise not within
the time scale for the judicial review
or at any time thereafter and therefore
you left with point G about the
proportionality of exercising this
particular power and as I say in my
closing remarks that paragraph
five of my report on page seven given
the circumstances that I described my
view is that an average ordinary member
of the public in this district might
find it quite difficult to see why the
council would want to remote revoke this
planning permission and listed building
consent when it would have to pay
compensation to the developer as a
consequence given the circumstances and
the barristers view about the planning
managers advice I think I'll end it
there except to say that there is a
document that I've sourced from the
internet
occasionally researchers assist
parliamentary committees and I've got a
briefing paper here it's it's dated from
July of 2016 so it's a couple of years
old
and it's headed revocation of planning
permission and it is a it's a briefing
the House of Commons library briefing
and it makes quite interesting reading
for a number of reasons but one of them
is about what happens when there are
alleged procedural flaws in a planning
decision and what we have here is
actually an extract from sweet & Maxwell
planning encyclopedia so I'm going to
quote this to you because I do find this
quite interesting it says however if a
planning permission has been granted in
a way that was improper and invalid it
may not be expedient for the local
planning authorities commence revocation
proceedings under this section and to
pay compensation the court made sted
quash the permission on an application
for judicial review without liability to
compensation such an application may be
made by a person supported by the
council though the court in such a case
have particularly regard to the effect
on third parties of course we we can
have situations where there are
procedural flaws in making planning
permissions and where that we face a
challenge then what happens is that
legal services will evaluate the risk
and act accordingly and I can say that
we have had instances of this council
rather though that maybe where we have
invited a challenger to submit a
judicial review application and then we
have conceded it thereby settling the
matter and escaping from any statutory
compensation thank you right thank you
mr. Grafton before we move on to
committee questions for mr. Baskin I was
a bit really celiac
members make sure members of public
people make sure their mobile phones are
switched off or on silent I'm sure
you're all have I did just have to check
mine and can you also give the common
courtesy to our speakers that allowed to
speak without any interruptions and
again I'm assure you we'll be following
that as well so just a brief reminder so
thank you very much any questions for
mr. Grafton councillor Richards thank
you I just wanna get my in my mind the
procedure that we could be going through
all we are going through so if this
committee were minded to make a
revocation order we would need to have
the applicants consent in order for that
to be upheld or that what if that was
withheld by the applicant
the decision would then need be called
in by Secretary of State decision we've
made by by Thursday correct not quite so
if you if you turn to my report
paragraph 1.18 we run today through two
initially at least 0.7 which is the end
of the process of the parties
submissions and then you decide whether
to debate did make the request or not
and if you do debate it you decide today
whether you are quote minded to revoke
the planning consent if the answer is
yes we are minded to it doesn't mean
that you will but you you are favoring
at this point in time doing that you
will adjourn the meeting and
report will go to the cabinet then
you'll have a view from cabinet that
will come back and you will sit again
and you consider the matter again in the
light of that financial view the budget
so forth if you're new decide as a final
decision that you want to make a
revocation order then there is a process
whereby you give notice of that to the
parties the parties and and then you
there is a time limit for them to agree
to that and in the event that they don't
agree that's the point at which the
Secretary of State gets involved so you
actually answer my part to a question
first which is quite relevant because
that leads to how we get to that
decision which is quite helpful let's
say we get to that stage hypothetically
speaking the part is the applicant in
this case agree to revoke we pay
compensation if required what's to stop
and resubmitting almost exactly the same
application on the back of that I can I
there's nothing to stop them submitting
the application again so ultimately we
could find ourselves in a position of
having revoked something as a result of
what what could be perceived as a
serious error or misleading from an
officer paying compensation and then
having to decide again on precisely the
same application and we could find
ourselves granting that application if
there's no potential for there to be or
provided procedures for it correctly is
that right thank you
just ask a question Ross how much legal
weight does the revocation hold so he
did come back to committee and we the
same thing came back to committee
and we fought already revoked by an
application with the second application
have to heard on its own merits not
spacing I'm asking it would yes and if
the revocation was for technical
procedure errors then those errors
aren't made again it shouldn't have any
bearing if it came back to committee it
would just be decided on its planning
merits thank you
do you want to ask a question press the
Barnes ok cancer Brian I can give a view
or your legal adviser can give a few I
suppose as monitoring officer if I can
put my other hat on for a moment I would
say you've got to choose one or the
other
yeah so you're kind of committed tonight
I'm sorry
you you you really would not be advised
to take part as a cabinet part of the
cabinet okay thank you any more
questions
right Thank You mr. Grafton Council
richest can you tell me what's quorum
for the cabinet is it 5:00
it's just just there where this
gentleman whilst we found answer to
cancer riches
um Russ I'm the problem
I'll get issue with this one sir just
checking the fact that's not related to
this application and mr. Grafton has
volunteered to assist with the process
three
you know just think of them that if you
weren't able to attend or take part in
covering it you will be down to four
members and it needs to be three to the
core it so that's okay I've just been
advised that we do need to as part of
the meeting declared any any
declarations of interest on this matter
we haven't actually decided them as part
of the process it is going really well
tonight so but again just to make sure
we're so we're not challenged so if you
have any declarations of interest and I
think that goes to and catch the bones
and I would declare we're not members of
the company I think you're free to go
mr. bufferton thank you
okay to catch the hoedown
don't eat mr. Chen we have got just one
speaker from each side is that correct
yeah just state you have one speaking
you catch the cargo have you greedy
generation we haven't ten minutes in the
procedure
have you any any thoughts on the matter
or would you like to ask would you be
happy with senator would you happy with
it's not long bear in mind we've changed
what you wanted to do I'm just to
clarify what I'd wanted to do I had
discussed everybody viewing the video in
its entirety when I first requested to
the revocation because I felt it's very
important evidence I was then told it
would be too long and that was
understandable and discussed clips and
the it wasn't something thought up today
it's taken quite a lot of time to get
them together and provide the scripts
for everybody with the quotations for
anyone that may have struggled with the
clarity on the audio so it wasn't just
brought in today it was actually it's
been thought of for quite a while and
that was discussed with the portfolio
holder for planning and with the group
leader and the chairman of the council
and it was submitted to committee
services and discussed with David Platts
from an IT perspective so it hasn't just
been hoisted upon the hearing as it were
so that's why they were clips because I
was told it'd be too long to you to
watch the entire webcast so just so you
didn't have to suddenly brought
something along thinking it might be ok
quite a lot of prep went into that so
that was that was the first thing about
the video so just make a comment on that
please we had agreed the process on the
meet on the 7th of the 2nd of May and
hadn't been agreed with any changes
would agree did the chairman and
planning committee whether it be
previous Jarrell myself
so therefore I'll be struggling to see
how you were after fit all those clips
in with with two minutes that have been
originally agreed so I accept your point
and I think there are some blood points
there but I think that I think there are
only importance but I think the template
in Mitch was agreed as part of the
process on the second of my but what I'm
will be asking members whether that be
mind you to give you some a few extra
minutes to make your points and also the
the applicant as well will be allowed
the same amount of time comparable time
so it's natural does justice is seen to
be observed so I'm more than minded to
agree to an extra five minutes if you
need them I'm seeking support from my
fellow committee members but I'll be
happy to read without ya minutes just to
be clear be 15 minutes speakers each
side each part each side yes and anybody
happy to second that proposal and all
those in favor
secret point of clarification on that
does that mean my presentation and
because the residents are here as well
does that mean that that's their
presentation as well included in that 15
minutes again because they went on the
original procedure that was agreed back
on the second domain I'm just I'm really
confused as to the information I've been
receiving about what was going to be
happening this evening because I
wouldn't push boundaries and try and go
against a procedure that was agreed I
was told that there was some flexibility
and that's why I've brought this
different type of presentation along so
I'm not questioning your flexibility
counts coggle at all I'm just saying
that there's just two camps of
information that's been received here
that's yeah I think we I think we have
been you know I think you're being I
completely appreciate your time and the
flexibility on that but I'm just
explaining that there's been a lot of
information that's been banded around
tonight we've had this so it is very
difficult to appreciate that as Richards
for clarity are the residents expecting
to speak and do they have who's looking
at this procedure list there is no spot
are we inviting them to speak with
cancer is on on now or other because the
impression is I get I get the impression
they're expecting to speak later and
they're not really an option no there
will be part of this normal time and the
ward member would be separate so we do
any different
yeah thank you are we okay on yes but
they'd like to
can't slow down how would you like the
15 minutes bits we're in your hands here
and we're happy to give a warning after
if you can give me a warning at 10
minutes I'll hand over to it to solid
black well okay thank you very much
right so far away when you already thank
you
first well I just put the question why
is a spectrum of any misleading advice
acceptable to be slightly misleading or
wholly misleading misleading in totality
it's just not not on when you're dealing
with planning and I'd like to read you
the inspectors final sentence in his
conclusion for his dismissal of the
appeal to the previous application are
set out in paragraph 36 of his report in
the absence of any public benefit or
material considerations to outweigh
these harms I find the proposal be
contrary to policies a s 10 to CS 8 and
CS 15 of the core strategy and the
framework this was not the picture
painted by the applicants agent mr.
Bromley the cherry-picked items from the
report to support the application a
point picked up by the council's
planning solicitors letter of
instruction to the barrister quote the
applicants agent was a little misleading
and he said the inspector dismissed the
appeal for design reasons only and I
quote from mr. Bromley on the evening he
said this second application introduces
a number of design changes that have
been made to address concerns the
impedance vector the expect to dismiss
the appeal only for design reasons
that's right and if you do need to
slightly slightly longer lines just to
make sure you just make sure that
members are yeah that's fine
right if when to start again I would
like to read to you the inspectors final
sentence in his conclusion for his
dismissal of the appeal of the previous
application as set out in paragraph 36
of his report in the absence of any
public benefit or material consideration
to outweigh these harms I find the
proposal would be contrary to policies a
s10 cs8 and CS 15 of the core strategy
and framework this was not the picture
painted by the applicants agent mr.
Bromley as he cherry picked items from
the report to support the application a
point picked up by the council's
planning solicitors letter of
instruction to the barrister quote the
applicants agent was a little misleading
when he said that the inspector
dismissed the appeal only for design
reasons to quote from the evening mr.
Bromley said this second application
introduces a number of design changes
that have been made to address the
concerns of the appeal inspector the
inspector dismiss the application only
for design reasons he commented on all
planning issues raised by the planning
authority by local representatives and
by neighbors but only dismissed the
appeal of the design reasons he found
all other aspects of the scheme to be
acceptable we believe the planning
manager during points of clarification
rather than clarifying mr. Brahe's error
compounded it members of the Planning
Committee rely on officers to provide
clear transparent and factually correct
advice in a neutral fashion and this did
not happen on August a second in the
same letter of instruction to the
barrister the solicitor stated the
Planning Manager misled the committee
about the inspectors report leaving the
committee I quote a little hazy at times
as to who said what judge Council
O'Donnell is discussing items there on
blue papers
I'm naming the instructions to count so
I think what advice I have to move that
pursuant to section 100 a foreign
brackets of the Local Government Act
1972 as amended the public excluded from
the remaining business of the meeting in
view of the fact that the nature of the
proceedings will be such that if the
public were present there would be
likely to be disclosure to them of isn't
information under paragraphs two and
three of part one of schedule travel
very to the said Act as amended just
bear with me one second
do you mean by the public because
apparently everybody that's here is here
in connection with either the applicant
or the objectors so there are no wider
members of the public so certainly the
agent applicants agent that's seen the
blue papers and barrister caps rode on
or seen the blue papers I'm not not sure
if the local residents have seen the
blue papers but the advice I just
received is that if all the public that
are here here in connection with either
the objects is all the applicants then
they don't have to leave